Insidious The Red Doors Twisted journey
into a demonic nightmare hits audiences
with some serious sharks let's peek
behind the red door at the creepiest
moments from the new movie
even before the film's title comes onto
the screen The Red Door gets audiences
Hearts pumping with a suspenseful
sequence the opening moments of The Red
Door are actually more sad than scary as
we're introduced to the Lambert family
at the funeral of Josh's mother Lorraine
there we come to see that Josh and Renee
have gone through a divorce because of
Josh's memory struggles and the painful
past they've gone through together which
has also caused Josh and Dalton to have
a strange relationship the scene
instantly brings out some emotional pain
within Josh does present throughout the
film however it also gives us our first
taste of the hair-raising suspense to
come when Josh gets into his car to text
Dalton there's a strange looking figure
slowly shambling towards Josh's car from
behind given this franchise's history we
already know that nothing good can come
from something like that thankfully
before I can do anything to Josh he
starts to drive away while nothing too
dire happens the suspense of this
sequence sets the tone and shows that
Josh's reconnection with the further has
already begun
Dalton's first art class was a very
intense Professor armagen starts off
very well but takes a demonic turn while
Dalton is able to make a first good
impression her next assignment for him
ends up unexpectedly making his
connection to the further grow stronger
as he relaxes into his next piece and
starts vigorously drawing something the
picture that starts to form represents
the door to the further that's starting
to reopen as a viewer it's so easy to
become hypnotized by Dalton's fast
drawing movements and the creepy door
that starts to come together however
what makes us seem terrifying is a
sudden jump scare that comes from
Dalton's hand being slammed into the
canvas causing blood to Splatter and
giving the door a sickening red color
the noise and sudden appearance of a
burned up hand make this scene probably
the best and most effective jump scare
of the film it's the kind of scare that
catches everyone off guard and leaves
him shaking with every suspenseful
sequence that follows fearful of what
will come next
our family has been keeping secrets they
suppressed our memories to better
understand why his memory has been so
foggy for the last couple years Josh
decides to seek professional help by
going to a doctor so that they can
perform an MRI at first the appointment
seems pretty routine but once Josh is in
the scanning machine for a bit the
lights suddenly turn off and Josh
becomes stuck with no one seemingly
around to help the audience says it's
clear that he's become sucked into the
further and it doesn't take long for a
horrifying figure to appear initially
the creepy and dead medical patient
appears behind Josh's head and nearly
touches him with his disgusting hand
when Josh looks behind him there's no
one there but when he quickly turns to
look forward again you can see the
figures scuttling towards him out of the
dark luckily Josh gets brought back to
reality just in time bird is told by the
doctor that he was merely sleeping the
doctor might not have found anything
wrong with Josh but this scene is a
horrifying sign of worse things to come
although Dalton isn't interesting in
attending a local frat party at first
his eccentric new roommate Chris pulls
him along for the night before the
festivity start frat leader Nick tells a
party about her previous incident where
somebody died from over intoxication
later in Nick's bedroom Dalton tries to
help someone he is violently throwing up
in the bathroom however he comes to see
that it's the spirit of the boy who died
in the Frat House who was covered in
vomit Dalton's attempt to hide from The
Entity under next bed only works for so
long though when Dalton tries to make a
break for it the entity quickly catches
him and proceeds to vomit all over him
thankfully again none of this is real
Chris finds Dalton afraid but not
covered in ghost vomit it's a sequence
full of stomach churning suspense and
visuals that no viewer will forget
per the doctor's orders Josh attempts to
strengthen his memory by playing a
classic memory game where he's tasked
with remembering where two of the same
photo are in a grid however his game is
really interrupted by that same presence
who stalked him in the opening The
shambling Entity is seen outside the
window covered in photos initially
standing across the street but slowly
making his way towards the house every
time Josh resets the game and changes
around some photos it's hard not to grip
tighter to your seat because the
suspense is so palpable eventually
though the tension is broken when the
figure crashes through the window and
starts to Chase and attack Josh
throughout the house their fight makes
his way to a bedroom where Josh thinks
he can fight back but he is ultimately a
match then thrown into a closet which
causes him to slip into the further
briefly Josh's memory game takes a very
scary turn that makes a sequence one of
the tenses of the film as it totally
leaves viewers on edge throughout
as Dalton deals with all the lingering
fear of what he saw at the frat house he
eventually falls asleep in his room and
slips into the further while we've seen
Dalton and Josh go into the further for
brief times throughout the film this is
a first extended look at them revisiting
the further at first nothing too drastic
happens as Dalton walks through halls
and even plays a bit of a prank on Chris
by playing her instrument while she's
sleeping Dalton quickly comes to
understand his power in the further
though and Bolton Chris starts to see
the results of his actions it's honestly
pretty creepy to see things from Chris's
perspective as she notices her
instrument fall out of thin air and the
door slam on its own yup that's not even
the most terrifying moment of this scene
the moment comes when Dalton is running
back to his room and a creepy entity can
be seen tailing him this is kind of our
first real Glimpse at the lipstick face
Demon's return what is far from being
the scariest scene of the film the first
trip back into the further still manages
to leave viewers on a terrifying close
call the further you travel the riskier
your journey will become
to gain a better understanding of what's
happening to him Dalton tells Chris that
he wants to go back to the frat house to
talk with the entity he encountered
there and see what he can learn while
Dalton's idea and intentions are good
things take a nasty turn once he enters
a further Dalton ends up putting Chris's
life in jeopardy when the Demons of the
further start to enter the real world
Chris is suddenly getting choked out by
a demon that appears and Dalton's
attempt to head back to the room to save
her is thwarted by a demon grabbing him
through the wall this leads to Chris
nearly dying and Dalton almost getting
stuck in the further thankfully Nick
resuscitates Chris and both her and
Dalton are able to leave with their
lives
after seeing the picture of the door
start to form something totally
horrifying Dalton decides to go deeper
into the further than he's gone yet in
this film and ends up in a playset
Insidious fans or instantly recognize
Dalton is transported into a basement
that seems unfamiliar at first Bert's
holds a secret that's been suppressed in
his memories for years as fans remember
at the end of chapter 2 that possessed
Josh goes full Jack torrents mode and
begins hunting his family down in the
basement
that's Dalton watches on he comes to
understand how fearful everyone was of
Josh and nearly sees his father take a
hammer to his younger self unlike
chapter 2 though Spex doesn't rush in to
stop Josh this time Dalton actually
charges at his father while Dalton's
actions might seem helpful it ends up
only pulling him deeper into the Trap
that's unfolding it's absolutely
terrifying to be brought back into the
tense finale of chapter 2 but it ends up
being the perfect way to kick off the
big finale of this film
elton's trip into the further only leads
to ruin as he comes face to face with a
lipstick face demon at first it seems
like Dalton is trapped in the Demon's
horrifying room but he suddenly reawakes
in reality making viewers likely think
that he somehow got away however his
creepy smile and unsettling demeanor
give viewers a hint that something else
has happened and it's not too long until
the truth is revealed it turns out that
Dalton never made it back from the
further as he's been trapped by the
lipstick-faced demon who has now taken
over Dalton's body
friends
it was bad enough when Josh got
possessed in chapter two but Dalton now
becoming possessed gives off more
daunting and dangerous Vibes that make
the whole ordeal truly terrifying
more Dalton is possessed by the lipstick
face demon he's stuck in the Demon's
quarters in the further which is pretty
much like being stuck in hell it goes
without saying but coming back to the
lipstick face Demon's domain is never
funny the evil red hint The Haunting
music everything about the place makes
you want to escape this hellish
nightmare as quickly as possible plus
you instantly feel the entities
dominating sense of control in this
realm so characters feel out of their
comfort zone as soon as they step into
the entity's domain with the red door
all these elements are elevated to
horrifying New Heights sticking
audiences smack dab in a legitimately
scary scene
after the lipstick face demon leaves
Dalton's body to stop Josh and Dalton in
the further Chris starts to work on a
plan to save Dalton by using strings of
light to bring him back to his body
however that plan doesn't work for long
as other entities from the further start
to invade the room and work their way
towards her and Dalton's lifeless body
it genuinely feels like a scene in a
zombie movie where horrifying creatures
just start to pour into the room and
Surround helpless victims thankfully
nothing fatal occurs as the entities
disappear once Dalton is able to return
to reality however there's no forgetting
the chills and thrills that came from
Chris suffering another close brush with
death and it leads into the final
moments of Dalton and Josh fighting back
their past demons
even though Dalton doesn't want to leave
his father in the further Josh tells him
to run while he attempts to keep the
door to the further shot for good it's
an emotional Sacrifice by Josh that acts
as Redemption for him as a failed father
but it nearly comes to nothing not even
Josh can hold that red-faced entity back
the Demon's face peering out of the hole
in the door is downright haunting and
there's a lot of suspense built into
this moment of Josh doing everything he
can to keep the further from breaking
out Dalton doesn't quit on his father
though and ends up helping him keep the
door closed by painting over the drawing
of the door the gross black pain to
watching over the door adds some strong
visual horror to the otherwise
fulfilling moment and that last look
from the lipstick face demon is
undeniably chilling the finale of The
Red Door certainly doesn't let off the
gas in providing some horrifying moments
and tense sequences as a Lambert's
closest disturbing chapter in their
lives
hello